>>> IT'S A 30-MINUTE FILM
CAPTURING A CRITICAL MOMENT IN
THIS NATION'S HISTORY AND MAY
MAKE HISTORY OF ITS OWN.
TWO DISTANT STRANGERS IS UP FOR
AN OSCAR NEXT SUNDAY.
IF IT WINS, ONE OF THE DIRECTORS
WILL BECOME THE FIRST BLACK
FILMMAKER TO WIN IN THE LIVE
ACTION SHORT FILM CATEGORY.
IRONICALLY THE FILM TELLS A
STORY YOU'VE HEARD MANY TIMES,
AND THAT'S EXACTLY THE POINT.
JERICKA DUNCAN SAT DOWN WITH ITS
CREATORS.
♪
>> Reporter: WHAT BEGINS AS A
BEAUTIFUL DAY --
♪
>> OH, COME ON.
[ BLEEP ]
DUDE.
>> HEY!
>> QUICKLY TURNS DEADLY --
>> I CAN'T BREATHE.
>> Reporter: OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
[ SHOUTING ]
[ BLEEP ]
[ GUNSHOTS ]
>> Reporter: A YOUNG BLACK MAN
TRAPPED IN A TIME LOOP
CONTINUOUSLY WAKES UP FROM AN
ALL-TOO-FAMILIAR NIGHTMARE.
>> I FELT LIKE IT WAS A WAY TO
COMMUNICATE NOT ONLY WHAT I FELT
BUT WHAT I HAD BEEN EXPERIENCING
THROUGHOUT MY LIFE.
YOU KNOW, THE NUMBER OF TIMES
I'VE HAD POLICE OFFICERS POINT
THEIR GUN AT ME.
AND THE NUMBER OF TIMES I'VE
BEEN PULLED OVER FOR NO REASON.
>> Reporter: 46-YEAR-OLD TRAVON
FREE ROTE AND CO-DIRECTED --
WROTE AND CO-DIRECTED THE FILM.
>> IT WAS HARD NOT ONLY TO SEE
WHAT HAPPENED TO GEORGE FLOYD
BUT TO PUT ON TOP OF THAT
BREONNA TAYLOR AND AHMAD
JARBURY.
IT WAS HAVING A THOUGHT THAT
THIS FEELS LIKE THE WORST
VERSION OF GROUND HOG DAY.
FEELS LIKE THE CYCLE IS THE
WORST VERSION OF THAT.
>> Reporter: THE LEAD CHARACTER,
CARTER JAMES, IS PLAYED BY
RAPPER AND ACTOR JOEY BADASS.
CARTER WANTS TO GET HOME TO HIS
DOG BUT GETS CAUGHT IN
HORRIFYING AND DEADLY ENCOUNTERS
WITH AN OFFICER.
>> DON'T SMELL LIKE NO
CIGARETTE.
>> ALL DUE RESPECT, SIR, YOUR
SENSE OF SMELL IS NOT MY
PROBLEM.
>> Reporter: MARTIN DESMOND ROE
WAS CO-DIRECTOR AND SAID THE
SCRIPT REALLY SPOKE TO HIM.
>> HE FOUND A METAPHOR LIKE THE
GROUND HOG DAY FORMULA WHICH
WE'VE SEEN SO MANY TIMES, IT'S
LITERALLY A TROPE.
H
HE'D ELEVATED IT TO POETRY.
ONCE I READ THE SCRIPT I WAS
ABLE TO FEEL IT.
THAT'S WHEN I KNEW WE HAD
SOMETHING SPECIAL.
>> Reporter: IT TOOK YOU FIVE
DAYS TO WRITE?
>> YEAH.
TWO WEEKS TO PREPARE.
>> Reporter: TWO WEEKS TO
PREPARE --
>> AND FIVE DAYS TO SHOOT.
>> Reporter: WHAT WAS YOU ALL'S
REACTION WHEN YOU WATCHED THIS
MOVIE FOR THE FIRST TIME?
>> I JUST CRIED.
THE MOST INCREDIBLE RESPONSE TO
THE FILM THAT I'VE RECEIVED SO
FAR IS I SHOWED THE FILM TO A
FRIEND OF MINE WHO IS ALSO A
WRITER.
SHE'S WHITE.
AND SHE WATCHED IT WITH HER
78-YEAR-OLD FATHER WHO LIVES IN
THE SOUTH, NEVER LEFT.
AND SHE TEXTED ME AFTERWARDS,
"MY 78-YEAR-OLD FATHER WHO UP
UNTIL THIS POINT HAS NEVER BEEN
ABLE TO ADMIT SYSTEMIC RACISM
EXISTS JUST TOLD ME THAT HE
THINKS HE MIGHT BE WRONG ABOUT
EVERYTHING HE'S BEEN FEELING FOR
MY ADULT LIFE."
AND IN THAT, I MEAN, THAT'S THE
DREAM WHEN YOU MAKE A MOVIE.
>> Reporter: THE 29-MINUTE FILM
WASN'T FINISHED UNTIL OCTOBER.
LAST MONTH IT WAS NOMINATED FOR
AN ACADEMY AWARD IN THE BEST
LIVE ACTION SHORT CATEGORY.
AND LAST FRIDAY, NETFLIX
PREMIERED "TWO DISTANT
STRANGERS" AT A TIME WHEN ART IS
NOT IMITATING LIFE, IT'S SHOWING
US THE REALITY WE CONTINUE TO
WITNESS.
WHAT DO YOU ALL WANT THE
TAKEAWAY TO BE FROM THIS FILM?
>> I WANT THE TAKEAWAY TO BE
WHAT CAN WE DO TO STOP FILMS
LIKE IT FROM EVER NEEDING TO BE
MADE AGAIN.
I WANT PEOPLE TO LOOK AT THE
MOVIE AND FEEL A CONNECTION TO
BLACK PEOPLE AND BLACK PAIN.
IF IT MAKES YOU THINK FOR A
SECOND WHEN I SEE ANOTHER BLACK
PERSON, I CAN THINK DIFFERENTLY,
I CAN UNDO WHAT I'VE BEEN
TAUGHT, THEN I WANT PEOPLE TO
FEEL THAT WAY.
I WANT PEOPLE TO DO THAT.
>> Reporter: THEN YOU'VE WON.
>> THEN WE'VE WON.
>> Reporter: EVEN IF YOU DON'T
WIN?
BUT YOU'RE GOING TO WIN, RIGHT?
THE.
>> I'LL TAKE THE "W."
>> Reporter: FOR "CBS THIS
MORNING SATURDAY," JERICKA
DUNCAN, LOS ANGELES.
>> NICE PLAY ON WORDS.
GREAT STORY.
>> YEAH.
I HOPE IT CAN CHANGE MINDS.
>> JUST 30 MINUTES LONG, AND AS
SHE SAID,